[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous montrer
quelque chose d'un peu différent
j'aimerais essayer de vous faire sentir
la joie intense de la découverte
mathématiques en particulier
l'esthétisme de l'élégance sublime d'une
preuve mathématique
[Musique]
alors vous pourriez me demander ce que
ça a à voir avec la série hashtag des
bâtons mieux
je vous propose de laisser cette
question en suspens on y reviendra en
fin de vidéo est pour l'instant oublier
l'importance de bien débattre oublier
les enjeux sociaux à venir
oubliée même le monde physique qui vous
entourent
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous faire
voyager dans le monde mathématiques à la
rencontre de l'une des plus belles
preuves mathématiques que je connaisse
[Musique]
les avant de plonger dans les méandres
de cette merveilleuse démonstration
parlons du problème que cette
démonstration résout
imaginez que vous soyez un enseignant et
que vos élèves ont passé un examen
manque de bol vous avez oublié de
demander aux élèves d'écrire leur nom
sur leur copie est pire que ça vous êtes
tombé dans les escaliers
si bien que les copies ont été
parfaitement mélangez bien sûr ce n'est
pas physiquement crédible mais oubliez
la physique pas aujourd'hui imaginer que
les copies ont été parfaitement mélanger
et que vous êtes incapable de déterminer
qu'elle copie appartient à quel élève
gêné vous corrigiez néanmoins les copies
et le lendemain vous donnez
aléatoirement une copie à chaque
étudiant
la question qu'on va se poser est la
suivante quel est le nombre moyen des
étudiants qui recevront leur propre
copies de l'examen
alors bien sûr ça dépend de la manière
dont les copies ont été mélangées
parfois aucun étudiant ne recevra sa
copie parfois plusieurs étudiants
recevront leur propre copie il est même
possible que tous les étudiants
reçoivent leur propre copie ok mais en
moyenne combien d'étudiants recevront
leur propre copie en langage
mathématique pour ceux qui connaissent
cette question revient à compter
l'espérance du nombre de points fixes
d'une permutation aléatoire
pour la petite
or ces textes
il m'avait été posée quand j'étais en
classe préparatoire j'avais alors
cherché à le tourner dans tous les sens
mais sans réussir à le résoudre
le professeur a fini par le corriger et
je me souviens très bien avoir été
saisie par l'élégance sublime de la
preuve tu me souviens très bien mettre
dix ans [ __ ] c'est magnifique et bien
un objectif aujourd'hui c'est de créer
chez vous ce même sentiment
d'émerveillement sublime
[Musique]
j'espère qu'à la fin de cette vidéo vous
vous direz vous aussi
oh [ __ ] c'est magnifique tic et en fin
de vidéo
promis je vous expliquerai aussi
pourquoi je pense que ce sentiment
d'émerveillement sublime est crucial
pour nos sociétés modernes et pourquoi
il serait bon de davantage l'intégrer
dans nos débats
[Musique]
mais avant d'aller plus loin je vais
reformuler le problème avec des cartes à
jouer
je prends disons sans carte à jouer que
j'étais ici dans un certain ordre
je récupère les cartes je les mélange et
je remets les cartes sur la table
en moyenne combien de cartes se
retrouveront là où elle était combien de
cartes seront elles des points fixes du
mélange de cartes
qu'en pensez vous avant de découvrir la
réponse
il est utile que vous passez du temps à
chercher par vous même oui je ne vous le
cache pas vous allez sans doute qu'elle
est ré c'est même possible que comme le
lait de prépa vous finissiez par
renoncer si c'est le cas ce n'est pas
grave du tout échoué à résoudre un point
de match ça arrive ça m'arrive même tout
le temps mais c'est vraiment
indispensable pour progresser en
particulier ça ne veut absolument pas
dire que vous êtes nuls en maths
le lieu de prépa a fini par assez bien
réussir ces concours malgré ces limites
cognitives en maths
le conseil que je peux vous donner c'est
toutefois de chercher sérieusement à
mieux comprendre ce problème
quitte à ne pas le résoudre échoué mais
ne renoncez pas essayer de tourner le
problème dans tous les sens et de
comprendre tout ce qu'il ya à comprendre
ou du moins tout ce qui vous est
possible de comprendre essayer
il n'hésitait pas à dire des bêtises
surtout sur vos brouillons mais aussi de
vive voix
il faut faire des erreurs en maths pour
progresser même les plus grands génies
donc jamais leur coup de génie du
premier coup comme on a d'ailleurs déjà
parlé dans le cade einstein et même si
vous ne le résoudre et pas en essayant
de le résoudre
vous vous familiariserez ainsi avec
beaucoup d'idées fondamentale des
mathématiques
échoués donc échoué encore et encore
c'est comme ça que vous progresserez
vraiment bref mettez pause et prenez le
temps de la réflexion
comment pourrait-on calculer le nombre
moyen de points fixes d'une permutation
on va passer à la résolution de ce
problème qui de façon stupéfiante tient
seulement en deux petites lignes
ça c'est vraiment le produit final de
longues réflexions parfois d'années de
réflexion
bien sûr c'est difficile à déchiffrer et
clairement ce n'est pas la meilleure
façon de comprendre ce problème
mais j'espère que d'ici la fin de la
vidéo j'arriverai à vous faire sentir
pourquoi ces deux petites lignes sont
absolument magnifiques notamment car
elles sont une forme de mathématisation
d'un changement de perspective
stupéfiants
pour comprendre cela reprenons notre jeu
de cartes et au lieu de considérer les
dix cartes je vous propose d'étudier
d'abord les cas avec très peu de cartes
c'est une technique très récurrente en
mathématiques quand on est confronté à
un problème difficile qu'on ne comprend
pas il est souvent utile de commencer
par un cas beaucoup plus simple qu'on a
plus de chance de pouvoir comprendre
je vous encourage à y aura davantage
penser à cette astuce la prochaine fois
que vous posera une énigme qu'elles sont
mathématiques ou non commençons par le
cas avec une seule carte
dans ce cas il n'y en fait qu'un seul
mélanges possibles et il donne
exactement un point fixe
bon ça paraît assez bizarre comme
premier exemple est assez peu
informatifs et on va même le noter qu'en
est il maintenant du cac avec deux
cartes dans ce cas il existe deux types
de mélanges de ces deux cartes soient
les deux cartes reste tel quel
quelqu'un on a deux points fixes soient
elles sont intervertis auquel cas on a
zéro point fixe voilà qui nous fait une
moyenne de 2 + 0 / le nombre de mélange
qui s'y est égal à 2 ce qui nous fait 2
/ 2 qui est égal à un point fixe et bien
il se trouve que c'est le même résultat
que précédemment bon camp et y est
maintenant du cac avec trois cartes
alors ça prend un peu de réflexion pour
déterminer tous les mélanges possibles
mais il se trouve qu'il y en a six il y
a 6 façon de mélanger trois cartes et on
peut voir qu'il ya un mélange avec trois
points fixes trois mélanges avec un
point fixe et 2000 anges avec zéro point
fixe le nombre moyen de point fixe pour
trois cartes est donc égale à trois plus
un plus un plus un plus zéro plus zéro
divisé par le nombre total de mélange
qui ici est égal à 6 ce qui nous fait 6
/ 6 qui est égal à 1 en moyenne pour 3
cartes il y à un point fixe
coïncidence
se pourrait-il que l'on ait encore un
point fixe pour quatre cartes cinq
cartes et plus généralement pour une
carte est ce que cette régularité vous
intrigue vous aussi alors ces cas plus
généraux sont rapidement beaucoup plus
complexe aussi mais je vous invite à les
faire chier vous essayez de lister tous
les mélanges possibles de quatre cartes
et si vous êtes bien motiver tous les
mélanges possibles de cinq cartes c'est
vous permettra de développer une
intuition des mathématiques des mélanges
qu'on appelle aussi la théorie des
groupes de permutations si vous faites
ça chez vous vous devriez remarquer
qu'avec quatre cartes
on a alors un mélange avec 4 points
fixes s'y mélangent à deux points fixes
lui mélange à un point fixe et 9 mélange
sans point fixe pour une moyenne de 1 x
4 + 6 x 2 plus 8 x 1 + 9 x 0 / le nombre
total de mélange qui est un plus 6 puis
suit plus neuf
ce qui nous fait 24 / 24 qui est égal à
1 et pour cinq cartes on a un mélange à
cinq points fixes dit mélange à trois
points fixes 20 mélange à deux points
fixes 45 mélange à un point fixe et 44
mélange sans aucun point fixe ce qui
nous fait une moyenne de 1 fois 5 + 10 x
3 + 20 fois de plus 45 fois en plus 44 x
0 / le nombre total de mélange qui est
un pur style plus 20 + 45 + 44
ce qui nous fait 120 / 120 qui est égal
à 1
hélas cette suite deux ans qu'on
commence à obtenir
elle donne vraiment envie d'être
généralisé se pourrait-il que le nombre
moyen de point fixe et d'un mélange soit
toujours égal à 1
[Musique]
en termes de mathématiques on vient
d'émettre là une conjecture c'est à dire
une affirmation et qui nous semble vrai
mais dont on ne dispose pas de preuve
d'humour pas encore de preuves
il reste maintenant à prouver cette
conjecture et là ça semble moins évident
mais parce que les calculs qu'on a
effectués pour aboutir à cette
conjecture semble long complexe est
complètement désordonnée
il semble a priori difficile d'exploiter
ces structures pour anticiper le nombre
de points fixes
à moins que
[Musique]
vous voyez comment faire
si vous ne voyez pas comment faire si
que vous êtes un peu comme le lait de
prépa il était resté bloqué parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas à trouver suffisamment
d'ordre exploitables dans la structure
des mélanges
il ya une bonne raison à cela l'ensemble
des mélanges forme une structure
complexe qui est difficile à exploiter
en fait espérer trouver de l'ordre dans
cette structure complexe n'est pas une
voix si fructueuse
pour résoudre ce problème ou du moins
pour résoudre ce problème avec élégance
il va nous falloir changer de point de
vue
vous voyez comment faire
l'astuce qui m'a fait trembler
d'émerveillement ce fut de repartir de
la liste des mélanges possibles disons
ici pour trois cartes et de simplement
regarder les cartes sous un autre angle
ce qu'on va faire c'est un simple
changement de point de vue
en regardant les cartes non plus
verticalement mais désormais
horizontalement
vous voyez pourquoi
alors que le nombre de points fixes par
colonne était variable et peu
prévisibles le nombre de points fixes
par ligne admet une structure absolument
remarquable quelle que soit la ligne
on voit que chaque ligne possède
exactement deux points fixes
ou dit de façon équivalente sur chaque
ligne
exactement un tiers des cartes est un
point fixe
alors est-ce là une coïncidence as pas
un hasard que chaque ligne possède
exactement un tiers de point fixe et que
se passerait-il si on avait désormais
quatre cartes ou cinq cartes
quelle serait la fraction de point fixe
par ligne
qu'en pensez vous
[Musique]
en fait à bien y regarder sur chaque
ligne chaque carte apparaît autant de
fois et ça ce n'est pas un hasard
en effet le mélange étant aléatoire la
cayenne carte du paquet a bien sûr
autant de chances d'être un as de pique
1,2 de coeur ou 1,3 de trêve or ça c'est
exactement une propriété qui va se
préserver avec plus de carte pour chaque
emplacement
chaque cas est et cuit probable
et s'il y a une carte chaque carte a
donc une chance sur aisne d'être à cet
emplacement
en particulier pour chaque emplacement
il y a une chance sur aisne que l'on
retrouve la carte qui était
originalement
c'est absolument magnifique
on vient là de résoudre le problème oui
parce que pour estimer le nombre moyen
de point fixe
on peut très bien y aller par ligne
plutôt que par colonnes le problème on
l'a vu c'est que par colonnes tout et
désordonnée et imprévisible cependant
par ligne
tout est simple
sur chaque ligne 1 sur rennes des cartes
est un point fixe
si on ajoute toutes les lignes on voit
alors que le nombre moyen de point fixe
est exactement 1 sur rennes pour la
première ligne + 1 sur rennes sur la
seconde plus 1 sur rennes pour la
troisième et ainsi de suite
une fois
ce qui fait bien sûr n suresnes qui est
égal à 1
on vient de démontrer qu'un mélange
aléatoire aura en moyenne un point fixe
cqfd
j'espère qu'on écoute en cette preuve
vous avez ressenti cette accumulation
d'excitation et de joie devrait
accompagner notamment ce fabuleux
changement de perspective
l'élégance de la démonstration qui en
découlent alors vous pouvez vous
demander ce que ça à voir avec la preuve
de deux lignes que j'ai montré en début
de vidéo et bien de façon stupéfiante
ces deux lignes en code exactement le
raisonnement que l'on dira de faire
tout d'abord c'était demander quel est
le nombre de points fixes d'une
permutation aléatoire et ça a d'une
certaine manière ça revient en fait à
calculer le nombre moyen de point fixe
par colonne autrement dit si on prend
une colonne au hasard et si on prend au
hasard un élément de cette colonne
quelle est la probabilité que l'élément
considérée soit un point fixe
d'une certaine manière ça revient à
marquer un point à chaque fois que c'est
le cas
les héros quand ce n'est pas le cas ce
qui représentait par le symbole que je
colle or ici ensuite et surtout l'astuce
magique c'est vraiment à la deuxième
ligne de calcul qu'elle a lieu cette
astuce consiste à changer de perspective
jusque là on a d'abord pris une colonne
puis on a étudié une ligne dans cette
colonne cependant de façon équivalente
on peut commencer par tirer une ligne il
prendre une colonne au hasard de cette
ligne est la magie de cette nouvelle
perspective c'est que tout devient
simple et ordonnée les lignes sont
beaucoup plus rangée et structurée que
les colonnes en particulier pour chaque
ligne on a une chance sur aisne de
tomber sur un point fixe
il ne nous reste plus qu'à faire une
petite addition et voilà nan autres
résultats on vient de démontrer avec une
élégance fantastique que tout
permutations a en moyenne un point fixe
puis dire que c'est magnifique
j'espère vraiment que je vous ai fait un
peu vibrer avec cette preuve est que ça
vous a donné un peu le goût des
mathématiques voir un semblant de
curiosité mathématiques
c'est vraiment l'objectif de cette vidéo
au final je me contrefous pas mal de
connaître ce nombre moyen de point fixe
le résultat en tant que tel n'est
absolument pas ce qui est intéressant
en revanche ce qui a énormément de
valeur à mes yeux c'est ce goût pour
l'élégance et la curiosité mathématiques
vous souvenez quand on est tombé sur la
suite de résultats égaux à 1 ça en tout
cas c'est vraiment le genre de truc qui
titille un mathématicien cette curiosité
encore inexpliquées
ce champ du savoir que notre cerveau n'a
pas encore exploré ce mystère qui
restent à disséquer
[Musique]
et puis aussi et surtout il y à ce
merveilleux changement de point de vue
ce bouleversement de la pensée cette
élégance du raisonnement qui éclaircit
tout à coup un mystère inexpliqué [ __ ]
que c'est magnifique
[Musique]
malheureusement cette curiosité et ce
goût pour l'élégance ce sont des choses
qui sont souvent très déficient dans
énormément de débat on a tendance à ne
pas se poser suffisamment de questions à
ne pas suffisamment chercher à
comprendre ne pas suffisamment être
titillée par les curiosités et à ne pas
suffisamment trouvé de plaisir dans
l'éclaircissement de mystère or sans
cette curiosité et ce goût pour
l'élégance ce sont des pans entiers du
savoir qui risque d'être ignorés car
sans eux il est très difficile de
trouver la motivation pour s'informer
surtout sur des sujets techniques
combien d'écologistes aujourd'hui ignore
les étonnants détails techniques
cruciaux à comprendre pour estimer
l'urgence climatique et l'importance
relative de différentes approches pour
l'adresser combien de technologiste
ignore les difficultés techniques à
rendre les ja robustement bénéfique et
les travers auquel des systèmes mal
sécurisés peuvent conduire
combien de noms matheux ont complètement
renoncé à s'appuyer sur les puissants
outils des mathématiques pour mieux
appréhender la complexité du monde
cette curiosité et ce goût pour
l'élégance se sont vraiment je pense mon
petit super pouvoirs
[Musique]
à titre personnel c'est même je dirais
mon feu sacré
ces aspects de ma personnalité que
j'aime le plus et que je tiens le plus à
protéger
[Musique]
je cherche d'ailleurs activement le
protéger typiquement en visionnant et en
revisionnant régulièrement les vidéos de
mickael launay d'alj et de swimming
world mais aussi celle de monsieur fille
de patience ou encore du cnca wonder
de prime abord on pourrait croire que
ces vidéos ne servent à rien détrompez
vous certes les sujets qui y sont
abordés n'ont souvent pas d'application
directe
cependant le fait d'aborder ces sujets
me semble indispensable pour prendre
soin de notre curiosité et de notre goût
pour l'élégance des raisonnements qui
sont souvent gravement malmené par des
sujets plus pragmatique et souvent plus
controversé malheureusement nous avons
tendance à beaucoup trop négligé
l'importance de cette curiosité et de ce
goût pour l'élégance du raisonnement on
a tendance à les malmener voire parfois
à les corrompre
[Musique]
surtout en situation de débat on a même
parfois tendance à dire à l'autre que
penser sans jamais prendre le temps de
susciter une curiosité ou sans jamais
motivé l'autre à trouver du plaisir dans
ses propres réflexions
le philosophe sean brennan prétend que
la politique en stupide et méchant
l'un des meilleurs remèdes semble être
de trouver du plaisir dont l'élégance
mathématiques
je ne suis pas sûr et même je doute
qu'elles nous rendent vraiment plus
intelligente et gentille mais je suis
persuadé qu'elle nous rend au moins plus
curieux est plus motivé à réfléchir
adéquatement aux grands défis de nos
sociétés
[Musique]
la curiosité et le goût pour l'élégance
sont le feu sacré sans lequel aucun
savoir n'est possible il semble
indispensable d'en prendre beaucoup plus
loin